Hello, everybody. Welcome to another holistic health hour. We had number of questions that came in most of you will be listening to this afterwards and that's good thing to do.
So, um, just a reminder, not to email questions. Um, you will not get an answer to email questions. I always ask through your course on the box where it says, please ask questions here.
So, everybody did do that. So what does your reminder for an oh is listening.
Okay, in your general considerations for specific cancers, minus melanoma and liver, should we take all the supplements listed or just pick and choose. So this person is asking these questions off the stock fighting cancer course.
And I can't answer specific cancer questions, but this is a course question. So the very good question. So in the stock fighting cancer course, we have different considerations of nutrition to take. So I say consider this or consider that because I'm not making specific recommendations for a person because they're not a full member.
So they're just looking at the course. So it's a very good question. Should we take all the ones listed or just pick and choose. Um, I just ordered my genetic tests haven't got the results back. Well, you're not going to get specific supplements to take for your cancer from the genetic test. So remember, when we look at your genetics, we're looking at different
snip defects and that have to do with different metabolic pathways that may be wise to support nutritionally.
They have to do with diet may have to do with taking a supplement or something like that because there's no research out there that if you have, let's say an HNMT gene defect will chance to do with the ability to make the DAO enzyme in the tissue.
And if you have a lot of defects on those HNMT genes, it might be good to support that even if you're not having a lot of symptoms. So you could have a lot of defects in specific gene, snip family. And you might not even have any symptoms, because maybe they're not fully expressed, but it still might be a good idea to prevent it.
Take some nutritional nutritional anti histamine type things maybe not on a daily basis, maybe a couple of times a week, I might have those on hand, I might take those on a pulsing type foreman, meaning you're not going to take them every day, but you might take them just on the weekend, or you might take them five days a week if you're having some symptoms. So you might pulse some supplements. No way to have those defects are going to take these supplements or
knowing I have those defects, I'm going to maybe not gorge on histamine foods, you know, and I'm not going to eat a bowl full of nuts that contain a lot of histamines.
I'll just, you know, be a little bit more wise to my choices. So when we look at your genetics, we're looking at those specific gene steps and giving you some clues on some dietary things and nutritional things to support them.
They will not tell us about conditions, meaning I have cancer, or I have an autoimmune disease, or I have hypothyroid, you know, issues, that's not genetics are going to show those things.
So, let's say I have, let's say I have melanoma, and I'm going to do my genetics is the genetic test going to tell me things that I should do for my melanoma.
No, is the genetic test going to give me some ideas, different pathways, different metabolic pathways that could be maybe, you know, a precursor to a disease, maybe.
But certainly not going to give you treatment parameters for a specific disease, so be clear on that.
So if I get to try to quote unquote, treat my melanoma naturally through our cancer course and look at some of the supplements that we suggested that you might want to consider.
Yes, you can pick and choose those things, so you can do all of them, you can do some of them, everybody's different, some people can't take a lot of stuff, some people should take a lot of stuff, some people are getting a lot of stuff in their diet, because they're eating really well, some people are dirty, really poorly.
So everybody's unique and you're going to make your decisions on that, so we're just giving you some advice that those are some of the things that tend to be good for that type of cancer.
There could be other things to try when I wrote that piece to the course, I tried to kind of wittle it down to maybe some of the more important ones, but yes, so that's a long answer to that question.
Another question, what is a red arrow pointing up or down indicate as I think this person is asking on the genetic report, so I actually took a screen shot of what I think they're talking about this red arrow pointing down in this case, and it's on the gene that I just talked about the HMT gene.
That means it's down regulated or up regulated meeting if there's a they're talking about the how you should deal with it.
This in this case, it means down regulated, I'm up there if that's at the arrows, but we don't, but if in so in this case, it'd be what was going what would be going on if it was down regulated meeting if you have defects on that gene, typically it means that gene is down regulated.
Let me explain that a little bit for those who don't understand full medical terminology, so if I have defects on a gene, so on this gene, HMT gene, let's say I had a double allele defect on these genes, that would tell us that from all the literature, if you have defects on that gene that gene is down regulated meeting it, that means the gene doesn't work as well and you could have issues with what that gene does.
Now, in this case, the HMT gene makes the DAO enzyme in the tissue to break down histamine, so if I had defects on this gene, I'm not going to make that as well.
There are some genes that with defects causes an up regulation of that gene, so that's where the difference of that is.
So if there's an up regulation of the gene, typically with a defect, that's a totally different story.
Different people can't have different issues with that too, but typically that's what the program is telling us is that in all the literature defects on that gene tend to be down regulation or tend to be up regulation.
That's what those are.
Do genetics tell a person about the best diet?
No, so genetics don't tell a person about the best diet, but genetics do tell us if the person could have issues with gluten, could have issues with dairy.
And, you know, some of the other foods that could be related to those things.
So if I have a gene defect that's related to the gluten that is the gluten genes, I have an increased chance of having gluten sensitivity, or I have an increased the other defect for the celiac gene, you have an increased risk of having celiac.
Doesn't mean you're going to remember gene defects doesn't mean you absolutely have that issue, it means you have a defect on that, and you have a greater chance of having a problem with that doesn't mean you're going to.
So it gives us that's why I speak throughout the whole genetic course about it gives you clues it gives us clues.
So if I have defects on that pathway, we make recommendations in our in our genetic summary and genetic action step sheets that maybe it'd be a good idea to to decrease gluten or to decrease dairy based upon your genes.
It doesn't mean that you have antibodies to gluten or antibodies to dairy in order to find out that you'd have to run an antibody test and we recommend the Syrex test.
So the Syrex test measures antibodies for different foods. So remember, genetic picture of somebody doesn't tell us a condition, the genetic picture tells us some precursors to what could lead to conditions.
And precursors that could lead to just some issues.
So it's not going to tell us what's the best perfect diet for somebody.
It's going to test it's going to tell us some clues.
What is fasted a good idea.
There are genetic steps that when we see those steps, especially when we look at a whole cancer profile that we do recommend doing some sort of fasting now with our cancer patients.
We don't recommend that they do more than a 24 hour fast.
And that's specific for cancer. And it has to do with up regulating the mTOR pathway after 24 hour fast enough regulated.
So increase release of growth hormone products and stuff like that.
So IGF1 is increased after a 24 hour fast and that can be detrimental to a person that has active cancer.
If a person doesn't have cancer, fasting can be a good idea. But you also have to look at other cold morbidities if a person is dealing with hypoglycemia, you got to be very careful fasting because it could make your hypoglycemia worse for a period of time.
But so it gets a little bit more complicated.
There's other ways to do fasting other than a complete water fast meeting that you're not taking it any food.
You're only drinking water. You're not drinking juice coffee tea.
And you're doing that for X amount of hours, whether it's 24 hour faster, 48 hour faster, a whole week faster.
And in any fasting, we always recommend that you go really slow.
The other type of fasting is what's called time restricted eating. So you're just picky to window during the day that you're eating.
And you start off with a fairly large window. Maybe you're going to pick your window between noon and six.
That's our window that you're going to eat between noon and six every day. And then at six o'clock p.m., you're not going to eat anything till 12 noon the next day.
So you're getting an 18 hour fast. And you let's say you do that three days a week. That's time restricted eating.
You might not do it every day. You might do it Monday, Wednesday, Friday. There can be benefit to that.
Up to the window, even more so if you've done that for a period of time, and then you've shorted up the window to three to six.
And now you're over three hour window that you're eating. And that gives you a 21 hour fast all that every day that you do that maybe three days a week again as an example.
That's called time restricted eating. Some people do time restricted eating daily. You don't want to start that way. You want to always do any type of fasting. You want to start.
Start mild. So I could never done any fast eat right now. You know, this is brand new to you. You always start with something very mild.
So that's the way to start with the fast. So if you've never done any fast, you certainly don't start with a 24 hour faster more than that because it can be.
It can be too much. I always go slow with anything, especially if you don't have a practitioner that you're working with.
You've got to make sure that you're going slow. It's a good idea to get a little decommeter. You can pick those up at Target or Walgreens.
It's a finger print test to measure your blood glucose. You don't want your blood glucose tanking in a hypoglycemic state.
If you've never fasted before, that's the danger of doing that.
But again, back to the genetics, genetics doesn't give you specific. Well, you should fast.
Personally, fasting can be good for everybody. Unless you person has cancer, they're in a kexic state where they're losing weight.
And uncontrollably, but most people in fasting can be a really good thing to be doing. It can be very good for your health.
Thank you, everybody, for your questions. We'll be back in two weeks. Make sure you use the question form on your course.
And I'll have this up on the course so you can listen to it. People asked questions, particularly when person was burned. So thank you much. Bye, everybody.